who came up with this business model is
there somebody that you guys say well
the founder of this business model was
john doe who used to be xyz and he
taught us to do this because it worked
back into whatever hundreds
is there somebody that invented this
system was it purely accidental
well you know empire the idea of forming
empires is as old as
you know modern sort of modern history
it's as old as history basically
um but the real turn
happened in iran in the early 1950s
so when prime minister that gets uh
elected president and again very much
much like jaime rodos
he ran on a platform that said the oil
companies
we need the oil companies here but
they've got to pay pay a fair share of
the profits they make in iran to the
iranian people
and uh the british and the americans
were the oil companies
in play here especially the british
company the company that became bp
uh and the british had no did not have a
relationship with iran so they called on
the americans
and it was eisenhower or first it was
truman truman refused to get involved
and then eisenhower became president he
got involved he tried to convince
uh most of that to uh to change his ways
and but it wasn't happening now
eisenhower you know ex-military general
was very afraid of nuclear war with the
soviet union
and iran borders the soviet union so he
didn't want to send troops in because he
was afraid that the soviets would
respond by sending their
own troops in and it could escalate to a
nuclear war
and so he got together his secretary of
state and his head of cia who are the
dulles brothers the infamous
allen and john foster dulles and they
came up with this plan
and the plan was that they identified a
cia agent a card-carrying cia agent
named kermit roosevelt who happened to
be teddy roosevelt's
grandson and kermit roosevelt
was sent off to iran with literally with
suitcases
filled with dollars and a few friends
he had a few you know assistants and
they
launched this huge campaign to discredit
most of that and you know they they
bribe the police
they bribe the hoodlums in the streets
to go demonstrate in the streets they
bribe the press
they use this money to uh convince the
country
that or at least to convince our country
to convince the world in a way that that
this
prime minister was very unpopular and
that he was a soviet puppet that he was
a communist and of course this is in the
in a time in the early 50s when when
there was this huge
clash between communism and capitalism
you know the cold war had really begun
uh and so there was this and in the
united states huge amounts of press that
that that that was paid for to to to say
that this guy had to be taken out
and so eventually he was overthrown and
it seemed like a legitimate coup
against a guy who was evil to his
country this is
this is you know the impression that was
conveyed to the world
and the chava was brought in
as a cia puppet basically and placed on
the throne the peacock throne
and so but this was so successful
and it was so inexpensive you know a few
suitcases filled with dollars is nothing
compared to sending in troops and it was
so
safe in terms of if if if it didn't work
then there probably wouldn't have been
war who knows what would have happened
to kermit roosevelt but but there
wouldn't have been a war we wouldn't
have
we wouldn't there's no threat of nuclear
war that it
it it marked a turning point where
successive uh administrations in the
united states
could say now listen we don't have to go
to war
to exploit other countries we can do it
economically
there was one problem and that was that
kermit roosevelt was a card-carrying cia
agent
if he had been caught it would have been
very embarrassing for the cia for the us
government
so very shortly after that the decision
was made to use private consultants like
me
[Music]
i thought it would wouldn't implicate
the us government
got it so this is why when you went to
your nsa interview
they said you may we may not hire you
but you may work with one of the
companies
that we are in partnership with exactly
and that became a very common practice
now let me ask you how many times did
the nsa throw companies like that under
the bus saying we had nothing to do with
it we had no
business with them was it pretty common
practice throw the companies under the
bus once somebody screwed up
well we always knew that they they would
do that uh
if we if we screw it up but i don't know
how many that actually happened to him
because i think
in general uh you know
we were pretty successful people in my
position were pretty successful because
these
heads of states of these countries had
damn few options really i mean
they knew the options